when it's on
martin i've made it bro what what before
because the other meeting's not finished
yet sorry
all right there's no pressure then
council barker so
you'll arrive late leave early sorry i
apologize
i'm a busy chat i've heard i've heard so
[Music]
thank you martin so good afternoon
everyone and um
welcome to auditing corporate governance
scrutiny committee for the new civic
year so we'll start with item one
apologies for absence please
no apologies been received thank you
item 2 declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary
interest and or other interests not
already on their register of interest in
any item on the agenda
and withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time council club
yeah just to register my interest in
1912a
uh i'll be leaving the meeting when the
titan comes up
thank you council club so that's noted
any other declarations
if not item three minutes of the last
meeting held on the 10th of february
that have been circulated taking that as
a proposal council kerry
yes two things i i was missed out on the
attendees
i'm pretty sure i was there oh you're
there i recall i can vouch for that
so with your
i am yes thank you council kerry do you
have a second to please
yes thank you councillor don't shout out
please counselor
thank you councillor so all in favor
thank you that's carried
so item for reporter external auditors
so the first is the audit strategy
memorandum
so uh is that over to you mr sawaj yes
thank you
so much uh and good afternoon to you all
um you have today our audit strategy
memorandum for the
year ending 31st of march 2021.
uh whilst i'll take the report as read i
think it's important just to
draw your attention to a couple of items
if i may
um the first page i'd like to take you
to is page
uh page 11 of your pack section one that
sets out the engagement
responsibilities summary as your
external auditor we're responsible for
issuing an opinion on the financial
statements
and i will come on to the specific areas
of focus for this year
in a moment we're also responsible for
issuing a value for money conclusion
the basis of that conclusion has
fundamentally changed since the previous
year
so again i will take you through the key
aspects of that
we're also responsible for reporting
through to the national audit office on
the whole of government accounts
and accessible to um members of the
electorate should they wish to
make any queries about us to
on the financial statements
the next area i'd like to take your
attention to
is the audit scope approach and timeline
and in particular page 16 of your pack
has a
a a wheel with uh particular dates
set out on them the first thing i'd like
to do is
give you assurance that's at this point
in time we are on track
for reporting and concluding our work by
the end of september
which is the revised deadline set by the
ministry of
housing communities and local government
for this year as a result of the
continuing impact of kovid 19.
we intend to carry out our work the bulk
of the work during the summer
with the conclusion period in september
there are of course matters that may
arise that are outside of our control
and should those arise we will of course
mention those
and discuss those with officers and or
escalate them through to use a committee
as necessary
the next area i'd like to bring you to
are the significant accounting areas
which are summarized
on page 20 of the pack
page 20 of the pack is a diagram that
shows that for this financial year
the most significant areas of our work
that we will focus on
cover four specific aspects
the first three are consistent with the
prior year
and i'll take you through those now the
first
is that under auditing standards
all audits include a unreboundable
presumption
that we need to carry out work on should
management wish it is in a unique
position to override controls
it's not to say that we have any
suspicions or
concerns in terms of officer behavior
but in being independent and
professionally skeptical
it's appropriate that we approach the
audit with that possibility in mind
and therefore design appropriate tests
as a result the second and third areas
are the net defined benefit liability
valuation that's the pension scheme
it is a significant balance in the
financial statements
very very large and also based on some
complex judgments and estimates that
include
the use of an actuary to help provide
the figures
as a result without that complexity we
believe it's appropriate that we spend
some additional time and effort looking
at those
the third area is the valuation of land
and buildings and investment properties
again these are large assets on the
balance sheet they also require the use
of a
qualified valuer to help with the key
judgments and estimates
in calculating the figures in the
financial statements so similarly we
believe there's an appropriate need to
spend some time looking at those
those three financial statement risks
were in the previous year
and we concluded with a clean opinion in
the previous year
they just roll through this year the
fourth area
is the recognition of covid 19 related
government grants this is a new audit
risk for this year
i'm sure you're more than aware about
the number of grant income that's been
distributed through to local authorities
and onwards into
the business and broader public
in financial statement terms there is a
financial reporting and
therefore audit risk around the
accounting judgments that need to be
applied
the number of grants came through it at
significant pace
there are some grants that will not
feature in your financial statements
and there are some grants that will
feature in your financial statements
that is in complete accordance with the
accounting standards and therefore
because of the large sums of money
involved and because it's new
we think it is appropriate that we spend
some time making sure the accounting
treatment has been adopted correctly
the next area i just want to draw your
attention to is section
5 which covers the value for money
conclusion and in particular i'd like
to take you to page 26 of the pack which
sets out
the key areas of our focus
for this year and is new
we're required to provide what's called
a commentary
on what the council's proper
arrangements are
now proper arrangements are defined by
the code of audit practice
and cover three areas they cover
financial sustainability
how the authority plans and manages its
resources to ensure it can continue to
deliver its services
it covers governance how you as an
authority ensure that you make informed
decisions and properly manage your risks
and it also includes a third and new
aspect
on improving value for money how you as
an authority
use information about your costs and
your performance to improve the way you
manage and deliver your services
our evaluation will lead to
a commentary that commentary will cover
all of the individual bullet points that
are set out on page 26
and will feature in the public domain as
a result it requires a significant
amount of additional time and effort
from ourselves
and also liaising with officers in order
to fully understand the scope
and come to a mutually agreed position
that our report is factually correct
i don't intend to go through any the
remainder of the report but it is
important for me to assure you that
we've completed our independence and
ethics checks
and therefore remain objective and able
to carry out the audit
in with due professional care
and on that note i am more than happy to
take any questions from
members
yeah thank you you've got more technical
difficulties with microphones sorry
are there any comments or questions
no thank you well um i think um
there being no comments or questions can
we agree to note
report from mr surge please can we
propose a thank you council shipment
secondary from council club all in favor
thank you that is carried thank you mr
sturridge for a very comprehensive
uh read-through of that report thank you
you're most welcome thank you so we
now move to item five a the sit for four
and corruption tracker survey results
over to you please jenny
thank you chair um yes jenny williams
internal audit consortium manager
and so this is a report that sit for
produce every year in relation to
fraud in local government and so i've
brought this report just to try and
raise the awareness of the potential for
fraud
and also i thought you would would find
it interesting
um the key areas of fraud for councils
like us are perhaps procurement
council tax business rates and
tenancy fraud is also listed but that
tends to be more of a problem in london
boris
so these are all areas that feature in
our audit plan
and we do look for things like
separation of duties which help to
minimize the risk of fraud
um but it's just really a reminder that
we can't be complacent that fraud does
take place
um it could be committed by anyone in
the organization from senior officers
to long-standing uh people you wouldn't
expect
that we did complete the survey this
year and submit the results
and so i asked all officers to provide
me with that details of any fraud they
were aware of
um but no fraud was identified for 2021.
um the report also then goes on to
detail the fraud prevention measures
that north east have got in place and
that's quite a lot um we've got lots of
uh
policies an audit plan that covers the
whole organization
we look at national fraud initiative
data matches
and we've got strong recruitment
procedures and we look at
potential council tax support frauds as
well
um so if our internal controls are
strong there's less opportunity for
fraud
so that's one reason you know we like to
see our recommendations and external
audit recommendations
implemented and but just to give you
some further assurance this year or all
of our
reports issued have been either
substantial or reasonable assurance
reports
so that means we've been happy with the
controls in place
so the recommendation is the results of
the survey be noted
along with a fraud prevention method um
that measures that northeast got in
place but
thank you thank you are there any
comments or questions
council shipment thanks chair um i was
just wondering
um i know it was just been commented on
that there was
no um fraud detected but
i just wondered if it built if we knew
were there any reports of fraud were
they investigated what were the outcome
um because not hearing nothing about
fraud in a big organization seems
not correct to me you usually find at
least allegations somewhere
that even if they come to nothing
um i don't actually have details of
perhaps any allegations that were made
and i
did ask officers to pass me any details
or any friend fraud they've detected
and in terms of the national fraud
initiative there will have been
investigations take place
and um when the next results came out i
can bring uh
reports this council of um
details of frauds on various reports
well potential fraud sorry
the investigations that have taken place
and
and details in that respect that would
be useful
all right thank you um i think it was
interesting that you said that you've
asked people if they've
committed any fraud and they all said no
well yes i mean seriously i think the
whistleblowing policy is there for that
reason
um so that anybody can report
potential fraud but i think the thing is
for us that
in an organization like this we do come
across fraud and
potentially through council tax um
housing benefit and so on so it'd be
interesting at some point perhaps to
have
data about the number of prosecutions
that they've been
the local magistrates court how many
have been taken to court how many been
proven and found guilty
and the amount of money outstanding to
council that's been through fraud
at that type of information
and it will actually be a lot less now
because the dwp
are now responsible for the um broad in
relation to
our housing benefits
thank you i think it would be useful at
some point maybe just to have an interim
look at that just to hopefully note the
decline as you say
um and that um all the things that you
are
outlining in this report are bearing
fruit and no one's got burner phones
nobody's secretly called h
or anything like that in this
organization
so are there any other comments or
questions
who's the fourth man you've just stated
yourself
so no questions uh kind of a proposal
that we accept the recommendations as
listed thank you council armitage
seconded by councillor clough
all in favor thank you that's carried
so we moved to 5b the internal audit
consortium progress report back to you
please jenny
thank you chair um this summarizes the
work we've completed since the committee
last met
and gives an update on where we're at
with the 2021 plan and we've issued two
reports
both with reasonable assurance um i
don't have any concerns to raise about
those
we haven't detected any fraud
appendix 3 then provides you with an
overall picture of the audits we've
completed
and you can see from that that due to
circumstances this year we won't
have completed the whole of the 2021
plan
um i have considered the areas that
we've not completed
for inclusion in the 21 22 plan which is
next
on the agenda that's done on a risk
basis and
discussions with officers um at the next
meeting i will bring
um a full annual report which which will
summarize all the work we've done today
in 2021
and so the recommendation is the report
be noted
and i'll try and answer any questions
chair thank you
thank you any comments or questions
now obviously uh housing council tax
benefit is in that report so we're
cross-referenced isn't it as a
inadequate assurance
at this time chair we've just got
laptops and removable media and mobile
communications that we've issued
in terms of this time reports
the oh and we we didn't undertake the uh
benefits audit in 2021 we rolled that
forward
we're going to look at it in 21 22
and that was really on the basis that we
we have done that one every year there
have not been any
staffing changes we haven't got any
concerns from previous
um audit work we've undertaken um
so we've that's one of the ones we've
missed for 2021
that's fine but it's just
cross-references with the report that
we've just had
and we've been talking about benefits
and fraud and so on and
also where it talks about ethics and
so again there's a there's a link there
isn't there and i know we're not doing
that at the moment but
it uh forms part and parcel of 5a
because as i said before
the only way is ethics
it's the best i can do so um
can we move to recommendations and
please
can we have a mover for those thank you
council army seconded by council shipman
all in favor thank you
that is carried so much item 5c the
internal audit plan
back to you jenny thank you
um yes so this is our proposed plan for
2122
and i have taken into account the
requirements of the public sector
internal audit standards
um has been reported previously due to
covert 2021 plan hasn't been fully
completed
um so some of the areas have rolled
forward into our 21
22 plan and this year you'll notice i've
increased the contingency slightly and
that's
so that we can react promptly to any
emerging risks or
due to covet 19 or on the path to
recovery
um so i've also listed a number of
reserve areas so we'll pick those up and
if we don't use that contingency or if
perhaps we're struggling to
arrange audits at a certain time
so the plan has been to the strategic
alliance management team it's also been
around the risk management group for
comment and the section 151 officer
um on preparing the plan we take a lot
of things into account so we look at
the level of perceived risk the length
of time since we've left
on the audit previous audit results
so if it was a limited or inadequate we
do them more regularly than
uh if they were substantial any
management concerns we're aware of
and then we also have a good look at the
strategic risk register to see what we
can
pick up from there so we've got 486 days
which is the same as last year and that
has the budget for that has been
approved by the joint board already
so appendix one is the plan itself the
column in green
is for 21 22. that's the proposed plan
and you can also see what we've looked
at in 1920
and 2021 and the last column the risk
factor strategic risk that's just give
you an idea and what the main risk is
um there isn't a magic formula that can
say how many audit days you need
to give assurance but i'm happy from a
professional point of view that
the plan there will allow me to give an
annual internal audit opinion at the end
of the year
so i'm recommending that our 21 22 plan
be agreed
uh and it just be noted really that if
we do need to make any major changes
due to anything that um control
weaknesses that might emerge due to
kobit or something else and then i will
bring that back to the committee
yeah before we go ahead
thank you thank you any comments or
questions
that's the shipment and then i'll come
to you council barker
thanks chair um just two quick questions
which might be obvious
but i i i can't fathom it united says
there's a grand total of 486 days for
the
year 21 22. how do you get 460
486 days of auditing in that time
um well that's made up of for north east
derbyshire we've got we have one
full-time senior auditor
a full-time auditor and a part-time and
then there's part of myself
so that's actually productive days so i
started okay yeah
yeah so sorry sorry i i i was just
trying to think about how do you do that
obviously it's labor time isn't it
and also um obviously we've just a lot
we've just touched on the fraud and
corruption stuff
we've only got five days allocated to
that
um you know then we've got like 97
allocators to written all homes
is there is there a reason that it's so
few for the fraud and corruption aspect
of it
as opposed to some of the others i think
it's because
it's sort of incorporated into lots of
lots of the audits so although that's
only sort of five specific days on
probably the national
fraud initiative results we will pick up
angles of fraud on virtually every audit
we do
so it's perhaps a bit misleading that
figure of five
okay happy with that answer council
shipment thank you council barker
county council audit as well and are
they really struggling for staff
to recruit people and and actually
get i know we've had covered but they
struggle to eat these targets because
because
they ain't got enough stuff are we all
all right on that front
it's an interesting time to ask that
question because the uh
senior auditor for north east derbyshire
is has um
achieved a promotion to another council
so we we are in the process of
recruiting
for a um a senior auditor
and we've actually got the interviews on
friday
um there weren't a lot of applicants but
we did have a few
quality applicants so um i'm hopeful
we'll be able to appoint
thank you interestingly that leaving
this authority is a promotion
but now they've done
glad you clarified that and my questions
about the
business grants allocating of 15 days
does that include all of those that were
given for
covered reasons um and ascertaining
whether they're
appropriate grants given during the
covid period
and there's 15 days enough so that's the
first part my second one
is on the l priority l refuse collection
we've allocated zero days
when we've just gone to taking over the
recycling
and of course with the new recycling
process and
taking over what was towards recycling
there may be one or two teething errors
and
issues and things cropping up in that
way is the allocation of
zero days appropriate
um in terms of the business grants yes
we were going to
um concentrate on the covered grants
and we've already been doing doing some
work on that actually at the moment
so which were part of 2021 um
so we were looking tend to be looking at
the systems and processes
rather than doing lots of testing um but
if the 15 days isn't enough
we'll be able to utilize some from the
contingency if we feel
we need to do more and it perhaps also
depends the
results of the national fraud initiative
uh matching on business grants is due
out in
may so it might just depend sort of the
level
of matches that are on there that need
investigation
and sort of how much work we need to do
um
and also as you just noted external
audit also undertaking some work on it
so
hopefully between us will i will have it
covered off
um in terms of waste management that one
was raised at the strategic alliance
management team whether we should have
some days in there
um it was felt that perhaps they wanted
to
um get it embedded and
they were in the throes of embedding
that and it might be more useful for us
to look at it
um sort of early 22-23
but we have got it as a reserve area so
um
we can look at we haven't actually have
we
but we could we can look at um
pulling that in or certainly uh keeping
a watching brief over it with the
street scene um i think my personal and
i'll bring you in a moment lee
um i think my personal view is that we
should
allocate some time to it and the reason
for that is i think audit at some point
will want to look at the amount of money
on street scene particularly with regard
to um
a refuse collection and the fact that we
have
successfully taken the recycling
situation over and
we all applaud that but we know there's
a lot of cost involved and we need to
see the impact
on council budgets we also need to see
that we're getting quality for money
value for service all those phrases
and so i think it could be something for
a forward plan
matter for this audit committee and it
would have been helpful for audit
internal audit to be able to comment on
any findings that you have from the
outset really
lee i'll ask you to come in now thank
you chair
yeah just to reassure committee although
it's not
identified on the audit plan
it's very much high on the agenda of the
risk management group
so in terms of keeping that close eye
from an organizational perspective
that's certainly
going to be happening but we'll take
your comments on board certainly i think
perfectly valid and i'll catch up with
jenny outside of the meeting
if that's okay i think is the committee
happy with that i think it's appropriate
for
a head of paid services to talk to to
jenny about that and making sure that
that's something that we can revisit in
due course
any other comments or questions
if not can we move the recommendations
that we um adopt this
audit plan council shipment thank you
are you proposing
second by council rowe all in favor
thank you that's carried so we move now
to uh
item six thank you jenny item six which
is the uh report of the information
engagement and performance management
manager would you please cath okay thank
you
okay so as you can see from the covering
report
of the 81 targets we've got a summary
there
uh 48 oh just under half of the targets
are on track
a quarter of the targets that are being
affected uh to some various degrees by
covid and then the rest of the report
has got the usual split of targets under
each council name so you can see the
status of the targets
under our economy our environment our
residents
and our services and then we've
reformatted the appendix to hopefully
make it a little bit more meaningful for
members
so at the beginning of the appendix now
we have pulled forward those targets
that have been achieved in this quarter
and also those at exceptions so
you can see a couple of targets there
that have been signed that have achieved
their out turn for this year so the
carbon emissions ones not achieved in
the way that perhaps the council would
have planned it's obviously been
affected by covered in the closure of
facilities
but the measurements been achieved and
obviously this is one to watch going
forward
and then others such as community grants
have been allocated as per the number
plans
and the number of e-electrical charging
points
has matched the target and that now
needs to be refined as target
of something more ambitious going
forward
the video remote interpreting solution
across the
contact centers and leisure centers is
now in place and operation and that's
obviously
uh a really positive uh development then
improving access to our deaf community
so that's
something for all of us to be proud of
with that achievement
as noted in previous quarters of target
05 under the environment
a struggle because they're not been in a
position due to resources to do
proactive
enforcement work obviously the team the
planning enforcement team are doing
enforcement work i don't want members to
think that's the case
we are doing enforcement workouts and
when needed announced and when reports
come to their attention but this
target was around doing proactive
exercises
um and that's not been been able to
happen due to the resource situation
there is a new principal enforcement
officer starting in july
and the head of planning already has in
mind a couple of exercises that he wants
to do in a proactive way during the next
financial year so
no reason to assume that this won't pick
up in the next
in the next year then a couple of
targets here that are overdue
one is a petition scheme which will be
looked at
in the next financial year that's been
discussed with the leader and
this target will be extended to the
following march to allow that work to
happen
in the new civic year and the review of
tourism
resource that is going to cabinet in may
so we expect this target to be signed
off in the next quarter
so that's obviously taking a little bit
longer due to the other restructures
that have taken place
in that department uh so that's uh
obviously the new head of service is now
in place with carl
and now the uh focus on tourism has been
managed to be done now and then the one
that's not started yet is a biennial
customer satisfaction survey and
that's work that my team will get
involved in once we've got a steer
from management as to how that's going
forward but we do need to know there's a
review of the consultation post at the
moment so there's not anybody in post
at this point in time and then we've put
together
for ease of reading the ones that have
been affected by covid
so these are the ones that are requiring
largely some
level of physical contact or
um where access has been difficult
because of restrictions
uh so there's quite a lot of information
there for members to look over regarding
some of these targets and then the ones
in here as well
as we've been reporting on for the year
obviously the ones the lesser ones
where the facilities have been closed in
the health intervention program
and initiatives out on the in the
district requiring staff so
as kirby's restrictions start to come
off we'd expect these targets to move
going forward and then the rest of the
appendix
is the full uh council plan listing
uh with those that i've just talked
through and then all the ones that
are on track at this point in time so
i'm not intending to go through that
level of detail
it's all there for members to to look at
so that's the summary at the end of q4
so that concludes the report chair
thank you kath any questions
counselor kerry
you're on mute counselor kerry
counselor kerry you're on mute
item that and it didn't come through
with the
official pack um
it was due to follow uh as i've only got
an ipad it's difficult to
see two screens once so i wasn't able to
see
that item it's one that we generally
peruse can i ask next time that it comes
with the bike in time not not
comes after yeah
can i answer for a request no it's
i was about to say catherine to answer
why it was to follow
yeah sure it's because we didn't have
the actual quarterly performance meeting
with sampton cabinet until last thursday
so the earliest i could actually issue
this report was the friday following
that meeting so it was issued on the
friday and governance issued it's a
supplementary report on the friday
the only other alternative was to not
bring it to this meeting and delay
to a later meeting but i wanted you to
have the q4 information sooner rather
than later
now that was a call i made so i'm not
sure
if on reflection that was the right call
but i think this information is better
if it's timely but i appreciate that
it appears that some members will not
have the opportunity to view the
supplementary report that was issued on
friday
yeah i think i think you're damned if
you do damned if you don't
we've always said there's an audit
committee that we
like to have information in a timely way
so that we can make comment on it before
it becomes old news
uh but of course um with the timings of
other meetings and so on it means that
we have this
report late in fact it was so late i had
it two minutes before this meeting
which makes it difficult for us to read
it analyze it
come up with the questions or queries
that we would like to
discuss in further detail so we don't
get a quality experience in discussing
the things that we might want to in this
report so i think council carries
comment is appropriate but i think your
explanation is also
acceptable kath and i think what we'll
have to do is move all the other
meetings
like some to make sure that it fits
around audit we are the most important
scrutiny committee going
well i don't disagree answer but i can
see the head of paid services agreeing
to that so i'll leave it in his capable
hands and we know who to blame next time
um so um but we'll press some of the
other
questions about the report so thank you
for your comments counselor kerry are
there any
other comments or questions about the
report
of course um the performance
um indicators about planning enforcement
we've mentioned before
it remains a concern for this committee
that while we know that yes it's hoped
that an enforcement management
manager will be in place in july 2021
planning enforcement continues to be an
issue
and those who are members of planning
committee and every single one of us
as a ward councillor will tell you that
it
is always a problem um
so this is one we'll probably be talking
in a lot more detail in the next quarter
because we'd like to see some sort of
action even in the meantime
before a manager comes because it can't
be just reliant on one person arriving
it has to be about how the service does
its bit to make sure that planning
enforcement happens
and so i i can't accept that that is the
reason that's put in front of us
and what is the service doing to sort it
out
so i'd like to see a bit more detail
when we talk about it in the next
quarter
also of course there's quite a few
things that are covered
affected and we understand that now but
as we start to
come out of the pandemic um
i think the hope of this committee is to
see a lot more of those
being reported on with actual rag rating
that isn't
covered affected and i think that would
be our expectation to see that in the
next quarter as well
they're the comments from myself having
read it very quickly
thanks for your comments and obviously
if members have any questions after
they've had a chance to read the report
then obviously just get in touch with me
and i can follow up on any
queries or any classification that
members may need thank you for that
katherine look out for a very lengthy
email from councillor kerry with all his
questions
i look forward to it so having said all
that you've seen the recommendation that
we note
the report on page three can we have a
proposal for that please
thank you council club second by council
armitage
all in favor thank you that is carried
so we now move to uh item seven reports
of the head of finance and resources and
section 151 officer
so over to jane for the corporate debt
quarter four at seven
a please sorry
this is the out turn position but i will
just put a little rider on that is that
we're still working through the final
position at the moment so some of these
main numbers may change slightly
but i'm i'm relatively assured that it's
it's it's accurate
draw your attention to appendix one and
just look at the sundry debtors
performance
i just wanted to highlight the current
debt position because it does look
significantly worse than previous years
and just reassure the committee that
that the lion's share
of those outstanding invoices or not yet
do invoices as they actually know
in the current debt category are to do
with inter-company invoices between
ourselves and ricknorth homes
or recharges with bowls over under the
strategic alliance
so with the 1.9 million uh 1.2 million
actually relates to
to those two organizations so but you
will note in column two the 90 to 365
days that is higher than
it has been in previous years and i
think that is
well almost definitely as a result of
covered we didn't do any recovery action
as you'll be aware from previous reports
for the first few months of the year
we are starting to catch up on some
recovery now but it's obviously going to
have a knock-on effect and take us a
while to catch up so
the other areas to report on there
aren't any real spikes you know paid
housing benefits or hra
um as i say sundry debtors was the one i
wanted to highlight with you so
i'm happy to take any questions chair
thank you are there any comments or
questions
you know council barca is looking for
inspiration outside
um so now so can we move through
recommendations please
to have a proposal thank you kevin sorry
secondary council club all in favor
thank you carried so much item 7b
on ethical investments so i've done the
joke already i won't do it again
so back to jane i wish i had that joke
in my chair when i was writing this
report
at the meeting on the 20th of january
you'll recall that we had a presentation
from our treasury consultants all in
close
and we got into a really healthy
discussion about ethical management and
the committee asked if we could bring
back some initial findings so
this report is just the initial findings
and i think from this we will then
decide whether or not then decide
whether we want to
to move forward with this so
environmental social and governance esg
factors pay
they are starting to play an increasing
part of decision making
but it's very much still in its infancy
across the country and across the globe
actually
and financial institutions are still
very very geared towards
risk of their investment as opposed to
the ethical
side of things at the moment having said
that the bank of england have stressed
their intention to do some um
resilience testing to find out just how
much
we are doing in terms of this work and
we're expecting that to come out
sometime during 2021.
i think they're seeing it very much as a
learning exercise i'm not expecting any
legislation to come out of it
immediately
but it will certainly be insightful for
us
i think in terms of our position um when
i looked at the portfolio of investments
our cash investments are very much
geared towards financial credit
worthiness but that doesn't mean that
they're not ethically
economically socially and governors have
to keep looking at what they all mean i
do apologize
what they they're not that doesn't mean
that they're not in those categories as
well
sorry i'll get my words out in a minute
we use credit ratings quite a lot for
this sort of thing so
feature moody's and um the other
organizations that are used but they're
the two main ones they do actually
um build in these esg ratings
into their measurements now when they're
taking a view
which i think is a good step forward i
think before it was just purely on a
financial basis but now they are
building these epson
so i think in terms of our fund
management
we're doing okay i think we're following
what the national picture is i'm not
saying that we couldn't do a lot better
though i think there is ground to
to improve as the market for these
investments does improve
and but one one interesting one is that
in lima the current strategy we've
recently invested in an rp
who takes environmental aspects of esg
incredibly seriously
so that made it very desirable to us
because it ticks the boxes it's a good
investment
in terms of returns much better than the
fund management
but it also um ticks the boxes in terms
of the esg factors so
this is something that we could
certainly do more of as we as we move
forward and look to
do more of that rather than just having
onboard money in the money market funds
as we have in the current portfolio
and they are out there there are a few
out there there aren't many um
eight percent of domiciled in france so
france are ahead of the game on this one
um and i think it's something that we we
perhaps need to watch this space a
little bit
i think my suggestion would may be to
wait for the bank of england report to
come out so we know where the national
position is
um and from there we'll be able to then
assess our own portfolio against the
national picture
and move this forward because i know
this is something the community we're
interested in so
i happen to try and answer any questions
on this on this subject chair
well thank you are there any comments or
questions
council um just a quick one and
when is this report from the bank of
england
my understanding is mid mid term of this
year so second quarter
[Music]
so uh are we able to get that coming
back to this committee whichever the
next available meeting is after that so
we can
obviously then move it forward however
we see fit
well i'm going to um agree with you
council shipment that it should be put
on to our forward plan
um which we're coming to item 8 so we
can say that the esg
investments comes comes back as a report
um following because it's on the
recommendations that the bank of england
will be um
carrying out their own review and that
at the an appropriate meeting following
on from that
once we know what they say we could then
put that as part and parcel of
where does north east derbyshire
district council go from here
um you've already heard that we've put
our toe in the water of some esg
investments but how can we further that
what else can we do to develop a
portfolio
that has esg factors firmly at the
center of it so um
i think to perhaps autumn time the
autumn of this year
we we can have that report brought back
to this committee
so we can add that perhaps as a
recommended recommendation three
okay so report
four to three minutes
yeah so i've added that's recommendation
that report be brought back to this
committee
in quarter three
are there any other commental questions
if not we move to recommendations so we
do have recommendations one that we note
the report on ethical fund management
too that we consider the
review that comes back from the bank of
england's biennial review later this
year
and item three now added a
recommendation that we
receive a report at this committee in
quarter three
um about ethical fund management
and north east derbyshire's part in
expanding its portfolio
with esg factors
so having added that can we have a move
of that please thank you council shipman
do you have a secondary thank you
council armitage
all in favor
thank you that is carried so much to
item eight
forward plan of executive decisions
are there any comments on on those
today we've added two i'm sure the
officers are always pleased to hear that
we keep adding to them
so we've got refuse collection report
specifically with regard to recycling
now that we've taken over from wards
and the impact on northeast armstrong
district council
and its residents and that we
also have an ethical fund management
report
for this committee in quarter 3 of
2021.
i'm happy to add those anybody against
i'll take it as we're all excited to
have those two added to our workload
item nine then um there's no other items
that i want to consider as a match of
urgency item 10 you've seen the date of
the next meeting is the 28th of july
2021
so i moved to item 11 the exclusion of
public
i move that the public be excluded from
a meeting during the discussion of the
following item of business
to avoid the disclosure to them of
exempt information as defined in
paragraph three
part one of schedule 12 8 local
government act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006.
can we have a second to please thank you
council hostage
all in favor thank you that's carried so
we now need to stop the live feed and
remove any members of the public
you